January 26th 2014 a commercial imaging
satellite orbiting over Saudi Arabia
captures an image of what appears to be
a brand-new airport hidden out in the
desert if you look at an image from a
year before there's nothing there it's
like an airport that's come out of
nowhere strangers still if this is an
airport where are all the aircraft
the mysterious complex has appeared in
one of the most remote areas on the
planet this desert is known as the rub
al-khali The Empty Quarter
it's the largest sand sea in the world
no government claims ownership of the
mysterious facility
the proximity of the mysterious airstrip
to the Saudi border with Yemen might
provide a clue to its purpose
this border in particular is
significantly important because Yemen
and Saudi Arabia I've had conflict for
quite a long time Border Patrol
organizations use light aircraft and
then they need somewhere to land an
online mapping website does identify the
facility as a border guards Airport but
something is not quite right
border control airports usually are even
closer to the border they're much
smaller this is big there's definitely
more to this Airport than meets the eye
Yemen is a focal point in the
international war on terror the
existence of a covert airstrip so close
to the border points to one unavoidable
conclusion this is the front line in the
fight against al-qaeda obviously this is
some type of military installation we
know for a fact the US has undertaken
many drone strikes against targets in
Yemen where are you going to launch
those from how about a base near the
border in Saudi Arabia
unmanned aircraft such as predator and
Reaper drones are key weapons in the war
on terror
drones are used for targeting enemies
that means direct kills
buildings visible in the image support
the theory the facility is a secret
drone base in the satellite images you
can see a trio of hangars that look very
similar to known drone hangars in other
parts of the world
you